hey guys I'm Alana what's up today I am
playing grim fandango which I'm really
really really excited about I've never
played it before but I have always loved
the soundtrack and have always been
really really interested in it so this
is just stupidly exciting i'm so happy
when they announced it was being remade
oh that music it's already epic
mysteries we're at who dis ready to take
you now take me take me with no no
there's no need to be nervous nervous no
just your appearance it's little
intimidating don't imitating I'd be
nervous but I'm your friend my name is
Manny calavera I'm your new travel agent
I don't want a new travel agent I want
to go home oh you can't sell so you're
dead but you're not alone everybody here
is just as dead as you that's why we
call it the land of the dead yeah
everybody's dead big journey know what
journey the four-year attorney of the
Susan typewriter it is quite a big trip
and I can't lie to you so soon it could
be very very dangerous unless how can
anything even read ainger is really
really dead though by a better trouble
package from us I mean wouldn't you
rather cross the land of the dead in
your own sports car maybe try a luxury
ocean cruise I guy with Chris chef if
you let a very good life you may even be
eligible for a ticket on the number nine
itself the number nine that's oh my god
i'm already in love with this it shoots
straight to the ninth underworld the
land of eternal rest in four minutes
instead of four years but very few
people qualify let's take a look at your
records mmm not good
the bad news is the train appears to be
just out of your reach but I still got a
couple of tricks up my yes just out of
my reach thanks for the compliment yes
that's the ticket the Excelsior line yes
she's a beauty that compass that's stick
sure come in handy too oh you're going
to have a great trip I'm pretty sure
that's just a stick why don't you you
could give me a lift oh I can't leave
here until I've worked off a little dead
to the powers that be community service
huh well I guess there are some folks
worse off than me oh I'll be leaving
here soon enough no thanks you didn't
know commission lowlife cases like yours
menso mm-hmm hey Manny oh I love him to
tell you not so the Grim Reaper works on
commission talk to you about something
when he gets back from his trip delle
donne not to worry right I'm not going
the boss especially not with clients
like that where do they get these guys
they don't qualify for anything good so
I can't sell anything good can work off
my time and I'm stuck stuck selling
walking sticks together girls free like
this little shoes I need it's really
just you know skeleton a real Saint I
need a lead on a rich dead saint Oh am i
moving I'm moving oh okay
it's a little red dot in the floor
nothing hello thingy yes some kind of
package a letter it's exciting it's some
sort of special work order to all agents
from office manager dan koeppel oh right
you boneheads thank your lucky stars and
get you your friggin cars we have a mass
poisoning on our hands too many dead to
assign specific cases so all clients are
first come first serve so let's see some
hustle out there ok ok let's get me all
right
hang on i should put subtitles on for
you guys if i can subtitles hello no no
subtitles text mode there we go we cuz
of course the first thing you do any
time you play any video game to spin in
circles am i right what oh never really
this looks quite pretty it's a nice
little sum sum Awards there you're a
legit gentlemen oh hey that's my photo
what what are you doing oh that's a door
my face is a door apparently look at you
you handsome with a lego look at you
moonwalk ah amazing well this is a very
very long hallway okay we made it hello
windows diaz Manny why aren't you at the
poisoning um any messages any messages
for me besides the one about the poison
yeah I only have one of the message for
you Manny I'm not just secretary I don't
take her sorry so get it through your
thick skull and stop forwarding your
paltry all right but that sounded more
like us to me oh yes I love it though
you're still my secretary Manny what are
you talking about I was never your
secretary even when you were on time got
one boss same as you Don culpa I was on
top ok come yeah come on I know you work
for a nap besides playing yourself I
don't know what I'm talking I know you
take memos for hurley sometimes um Manny
just beat it will ya where is everybody
knows everybody Oh Manny did you forget
one poisoning day oh man did I come in
on Saturday again it's the day of the
dead everybody's back in the land
learning their families like we should
be so it's a significant day I see all
right I gotta go hit the bricks ok you
shall I will thank you lady I really
like that um it actually says what the
text says
ooh hello money knock yourself out ah
thank you lady hahaha oh [ __ ] that's
beautiful um yeah if you play a little
bio I games you like I always get
annoyed that they don't say exactly what
the text says they kind of like deviate
from what I wanted them to say oh my god
no loading screens okay it's gonna be
one when I walk out this door look for
sure unless I can go this way I don't
really know what I'm doing but okay so
apparently it's ooh who had oh yes
that's a light looks like some kind of
speaker well these dolls Egyptian or
something I don't know um fancy building
though but yeah so it's the day of the
dead so I think that that means this is
when everyone who is dead arrives I
really don't know I have no idea no
loading screens what is this magic okay
not sure what I'm supposed to be doing
the poisoning something about a
poisoning this is my car doesn't look
interact with a bull we can't operate
cars that's how they keep us from school
account that's kind of brutal is that
why it's grim fandango and not happy
Fandango no this looks totally happy
what the [ __ ] is that been a giant
floating donkey this is the happiest
thing I've ever seen in my life I want
to join hello friends i'm walking down
this very very long street very slowly
to come and hang out with you all made
it yes
hey was going down clown in back off sir
I'm practicing practicing hard to see
what ring in your huh what is it look oh
god that's uh know what for you then I'm
gonna see the great well walk through
someone else's 10 [ __ ] this guy okay
your dick I didn't insult him who's me
up one of them I'll fella yeah yeah
yeahs twist this all right shows what
you know buddy I can do anything there
anything I can do birds and Vivian's I
just named to cast poets go ahead name
one okay a cat okay okay no prob this
exciting hope he makes one I guess that
looks vaguely cat-like [ __ ] yeah all
right that's it I don't need to play
anymore at this game I have a little cat
look at it oh look at it and a little
pink on earth damn it i just wanted to
show you my little pig cat no it's here
just trying to get to the best of all it
it this way no damn it
well you know at least I have a cat so
really I can call it quits now I mean
let's be honest sholay there's nothing
better I could possibly accomplish oh
this looks creepy it's okay it's
dangerous to go alone take this cat
balloon why are these hallways so long
no there's no way to go here really
why's huh maybe I can pull this set of
fairy lights no I god damn it I would
have thought that this was like a way to
get around into the festival was right
now I'm just very very lost but I have
heard that from people talking about
this game before even before the
remaster was announced about how excited
I was people were like yeah you kind of
get lost a lot and don't know what you
have to do and I think because of the
tone of this game I'm kind of 110% ok
with that because the dialogues great
and I feel like the universe is pretty
well fleshed out already I can you know
I understand what's going on it is it
the forced on me at all so I'm pretty
happy about this if I could just [ __ ]
get through to the festival I gotta
convince this guy reckon maybe I should
have been nicer to him some of my fine
don't you think I can't talk to him
anymore am I supposed to do here
come on man oh no I just put the cat
away no pull the cap back out oh no oh
oh oh yes thank you definitely a cat oh
my god I have no idea what to do okay so
maybe we just give up and not go that
way well the streets are so long though
where's the sprint button come on buddy
you'll get there looky blood and all
those calories you can do it but uh okay
purified for us huh that sounds good
feel like I'm gonna get run over by
walking oh I shouldn't even be standing
here why not
you already did you know I don't
understand what the problem is okay so
the only way that i can go is vaguely
towards this festival right unless
there's something that I done missed
I've already been in that building
that's where I work can I go over here
there's a door here let's have a look oh
so I'm gonna take that as a no I can't
wear a my god oh my god this is this is
ridiculous all right let's see if I can
give this dude something to like it's
the first yes that's why I want to be
any more of a living persons holiday but
it's the festival of the day of the dead
really more of a living persons holiday
but we play along
I don't know what that is examine what
is that my scythe I like the gas where
my heart used to be now we talk to you
that soul has already damn it [ __ ] well
it's an elaborate site look at it fall
down that's crazy ok yeah let's go with
this sort of special we're cool yeah
special work order memos are for reading
and throwing away nothing uh all right
well I guess we'll read it then huh sort
of special con [ __ ] man all right you
guys I'm giving up for today I'm giving
up I'm gonna spend more time walking
around here and i'll edit it out so that
you guys don't have to watch me have no
idea what to do i'm sorry but i'm still
entertained look dead birds look do you
see the dead birds maybe i can talk to
them i have a desire to have a pet
pigeon fine [ __ ] you then